welcome back everybody a lot to get to
today i i think
it is really time for the fbi to
act and formally start investigating if
they have not already
trumpian congressman madison cawthornes
completely
unhinged and outrageous rant about armed
citizens
taking over the u.s government and using
as an analogy
how the viet cong acted during the
vietnam war
against american troops and just every
layer of this
is trash this is a sitting congressman
he's part of this trumpian trio
lauren bobert marjorie taylor greene and
him
madison cawthorne this is sort of like a
new breed of elected official
completely devoid even of a pretense of
caring about policy they just run
offices based on tweets
memes political stunts and interviews on
right-wing media
there's absolutely they're overt in that
they don't even
pretend to be about policy this
political stunt should really have some
consequences
last week hawthorne who by the way
represents north carolina
i wrongly said a couple weeks ago he
represents south carolina madison
catherine representing north carolina in
the house uh was being interviewed by
newsmax host chris
salcedo now chris salcedo has had me on
his radio show you can find how
that went there's a clip on my youtube
channel and kawthorne
specifically said about those who say
that having small arms meaning firearms
wouldn't be useful in overthrowing the
government if the government were to
become tyrannical
he says no no no it is possible look at
how the viet cong
handled the united states marines and
the united states army during the
vietnam war
take a look at this you didn't see that
what i'm making allusion to but
he's asked i think it was senator
kennedy who asked him
define an assault weapon and he sat
there and said i i can't define
an assault weapon yet they want to take
something called an assault weapon which
you and i both know doesn't exist they
want to take it away from us
so it doesn't you know what i'm at
basically under my
go ahead yeah well you know i actually
saw him walk try and walk that back and
say well you know
the definition of assault weapons
anything that shoots a a semi-automatic
around something that you don't you can
pull the trigger multiple times without
having to reload
and it shoots that is basically every
single modern sporting rifle in the
united states of america but let me tell
you
the second is not written for sporting
the second amendment is so that the
tyrannical government ever wants to rise
up
we can stop them and if anybody ever
wants to say oh well you know what uh
citizens with a few small arms fire
would never be able to stop the federal
government
i absolutely disagree ask the viet cong
how they handle the marines in the army
in vietnam
now i i really am struggling with what
is the most absurd and disgusting part
of this it's hard to figure out
because there's so much going on i mean
the whole clip is 60 seconds
he's only talking for part of it and
there's just
so much nuttiness there first of all
again
the idea of the of the second
amendment's purpose
being for the overthrow of a potentially
tyrannical government as as the most
important thing the second amendment is
meant for
that's just wrong and that's disgusting
that's number one
secondly he keeps raising the viet cong
the viet cong the viet cong which killed
endless
american members of the military during
the vietnam war
he raises that as the model of armed
citizen uprising against our government
vietnam veterans are not going to like
that first and foremost but
it's most importantly a historically
really stupid
analogy to make because first of all the
reason
the viet cong was as effective as it was
at killing americans
was the americans came from across the
world and were fighting in vietnam
uh there is simply no analogy to a
hypothetical
cothorn force of right-wingers with guns
trying to fight the us army on u.s soil
it's such an absurd comparison
that it's hard to take seriously but
sadly
lots of the people who would be ignorant
enough to vote for this guy probably
hear it and say yeah
that makes a lot of sense and then the
other aspect of this that's absurd
is that even when fighting the us army
which had traveled across the world
remember during the vietnam war
the vietcong wasn't able to win anything
or control
anything they were able to wreak such
havoc
that they made the war really expensive
and difficult for the united states to
continue fighting the vietcong
wasn't even winning on their own soil
and it was their own soil after all and
uh
the the u.s military was halfway across
the world so
it's such an ignorant and and ignorant
of history
analogy and comparison but too many
right-wingers hear this
and they think madison cawthorn he knows
history
what an amazing young man that's amazing
what a smart guy the guy's a fool
and these comments are so borderline
unhinged
it doesn't seem out of line to me that
the fbi would look at whether people are
being radicalized
and getting involved in specific actions
involving guns
as a result of the nonsense that this
guy is saying it's it's
really an indictment again another one i
mean these are exhausting it's one after
the other
it's another indictment on the
uh intelligence and understanding of how
the world works of such a huge
portion of the american electorate and
as i've said before
if you overestimate the intelligence of
the american electorate you are almost
certain to be disappointed
the biggest example of that of course is
donald trump's 2016 run for president of
the united states
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique
online service delivering the same
active
ingredients as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free
so if you think you could benefit from
an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz on their
website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping